EXAGGERATING THIS ALL ALONG.
FLYNN WAS A DIRTY GUY AND
DESERVED IT.
WELL, THIS IS STUNNING.
MORE ON THAT AHEAD.
BUT FIRST, MY THOUGHTS AT THE
END OF DAY 44 AMERICA IN SHUT
DOWN.
NOW REMEMBER BACK IN MARCH WHEN
NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO
GAVE THIS VERY OMINOUS MORNING.
>> WE ARE YOUR FUTURE.
WHERE WE ARE TODAY, YOU WILL BE
IN THREE WEEKS OR FOUR WEEKS.
>> Laura: WELL THAT FORECAST
WASN’T EVEN CLOSE.
THERE HAVE BEEN 23,384 DEATHS IN
THE EMPIRE ESTATE AS OF THIS
EVENING, MEANING THE DEATH RATE
THERE IS 120 PER 100,000.
THE NEXT HIGHEST DEATH RATE IN
THE COVID IS JERSEY WITH 6,771
COVID DEATHS OR 73 PER 100,000.
NEW YORK IS AND ALWAYS WAS IN
ITS OWN CATEGORY OF CORONAVIRUS
SUFFERING AND THEY DID SUFFER
AND CONTINUE TO.
BUT CERTAINLY NOT LIKE FLORIDA
WHICH LOCKED DOWN LATER THAN
MOST STATES AND IS NOW REOPENING
EARLIER.
>> EVERYONE IN THE MEDIA WAS
SAYING FLORIDA WOULD BE LIKE
NEW YORK OREO THE LEAP.
AND THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTOOD, WE HAVE A
BIG DIVERSITY.
I HAVE LESS THAN 500 PEOPLE OUT
OF A STATE OF 22 MILLION ON
VENTILATORS AS OF LAST NIGHT.
AND I HAVE 6,500 VENTILATORS
SITTING IDLE.
>> Laura: SO IT IS WORTH
ASKING, WHY ARE STATES WITH FAR
LESS SEVERE OUTBREAKS, STATES
THAT HAPPEN TO BE RUN BY
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS OR BLUE
STATE GOVERNORS, LIKE VIRGINIA
AND NORTH CAROLINA, WHY ARE
THOSE STILL UNDER STRICT
LOCKDOWN MEASURES?
WELL, THEY CLAIM THEY ARE
FOLLOWING DATA.
SO LET’S ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE
DATA.
VIRGINIA’S DEATH RATE IS 20
TIMES LESS THAN NEW YORK AT JUST
SIX PER 100,000 FOR A TOTAL OF
522 VIRGINIANS LOST THEIR LIFE
TO COVID.
OF COURSE EVERY LIFE LOST IS
HEARTBREAKING.
IT IS TRAGIC, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE VIRGINIA
LIVES LOST TOOTH DUE TO
SKYROCKETING UNEMPLOYMENT
INCREASE OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE,
MENTAL ILLNESS, DOMESTIC ABUSE?
GEORGIA IMPORTER WHICH ARE BOTH
HEADED BY CONSERVATIVE
GOVERNORS, WE KNOW ARE
ALREADY OPENING.
THEY ARE TAKING A WHOLE STATE
APPROACH TO THE SITUATION AND
RECEIVING NONSTOP CRITICISM FROM
THE LEFT FOR DOING SO.
WELL "THE ANGLE" WARNS YOU WEEKS
AGO THAT THEY WOULD TRY TO KEEP
THEIR STATES LOCKDOWN AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE.
WHATEVER THEIR ACTUAL COVID
NUMBERS WERE REGARDLESS OF THE
ECONOMIC HARM OR CARNAGE THIS
WAS CAUSING.
VIRGINIA GOVERNOR RALPH NORTHAM
IS IN A CATEGORY OF HIS OWN.
HE WANTS TO REOPEN AS SLOWLY AS
POSSIBLE.
>> WE NEED TO SEE THE PERCENTAGE
OF POSITIVE TESTS AND THE NUMBER
OF HOSPITALIZATIONS BOTH TRACKED
DOWNWARD OVER 14 DAYS, ENOUGH
CAPACITY IN THE HOSPITAL BEDS WE
NEED TO SUSTAIN OUR PPE SUPPLY.
WE CANNOT AND WILL NOT LOOSEN
THE RESTRICTIONS THE WAY YOU
TURN ON A LIGHT SWITCH.
>> Laura: THE NUMBERS IN
VIRGINIA ARE LOW.
THEY ARE AMONG THE LOWEST IN THE
COUNTRY.
NOW, NORTH CAROLINA HAS LOWER
COVID DEATH RATES THREE PER
100,000 WHICH IS 40 TIMES LESS
THAN NEW YORK’S DEATH RATE.
OF COURSE DEMOCRAT ROY COOPER
WAS UNMOVED BY THE DATA AND LAST
WEEK, HE EXTENDED HIS
STATES LOCKDOWN UNTIL MAY 8TH.
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
NORTH CAROLINIANS DID NOT TAKE
KINDLY TO THAT.
THE PROTESTERS STORM THE STATE
CAPITOL YESTERDAY TO DEMAND THAT
COOPER RESEND HIS STAY-AT-HOME
ORDER.
WHAT DID THE STATE DO?
THE STATE RESPONDED BY ARRESTING
FOUR WEB THEM, INCLUDING AN
ORGANIZER FOR MERELY STEPPING
ONTO THE SIDEWALK OUTSIDE OF
THE GOVERNOR’S MANSION.
I KID YOU NOT.
LIKE, WHERE IS THE MEDIA?
THE FIRST TIME IS TO DO WHAT, TO
ENSURE THAT WE THE PEOPLE RETURN
OUR RIGHTS, NOT JUST TO SAY
PEOPLE THAT PEOPLE AGREE WITH.
BUT TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST THE
POWERFUL.
AND ESPECIALLY OUR POLITICIANS
IS THE WHOLE POINT, ISN’T IT?
OR DOES THE PRESS BELIEVED FREE
SPEECH IS ONLY WORTH PROTECTING
IF IT IS FOR AN ISSUE THEY LIKE
LIKE GUN-CONTROL, WOMEN’S
WOMEN’S RIGHTS, CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE TRUTH IS THIS COVID CRISIS
HAS EXPOSED THE AMERICAN MEDIA
FOR WHAT THEY ARE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE CONTROL FREAKS.
NOW, CHECK OUT THIS HEADLINE
FROM CNN.
THE ARTICLE SAYS "CHINA DESPITE
BEING WHERE THE VIRUS FIRST
EMERGED HAS COPED WITH THE
ENSUING PANDEMIC FAR BETTER THAN
MANY OTHER COUNTRIES."
THE ARTICLE GOES ON TO TOUT "THE
BENEFITS OF A STRONG GOVERNMENT
AND CENTRALIZED PLANNING."
WHILE EXPOSING THE LIMITATIONS
OF PRIVATE INDUSTRIES TO RESPOND
QUICKLY.
PARTICULARLY IN THE HEALTH CARE
SECTOR.
SOMETIMES, CENTRALIZED PLANNING?
AND LIMITATIONS OF PRIVATE
INDUSTRY?
I WILL TRANSLATE THAT FOR YOU.
COMMUNISM GOOD, CAPITALISM EVIL.
THAT IS SHORTHAND.
NOW IN AUTHORITARIAN REGIMES,
ELITES DON’T SERVE THE WORKING
PEOPLE, WE KNOW THAT, RIGHT?
THEY WOO OVER THEM.
SOCIAL CONTROL OVER LARGE
POPULATIONS IS ACHIEVED THROUGH
FEAR AND INTIMIDATION AND
SUPPRESSION OF FREE THOUGHT.
CONDITIONING THE PUBLIC THROUGH
POWER PLUG AND IT IS ALSO KEY.
NEW DOGMAS REPLACE GOOD OLD
COMMON SENSE.
>> THE ADVICE FROM THE EXPERTS
IS CLEAR WHERE A MASK FOR THE
PROTECTION OF OTHER PEOPLE.
IF THE VICE PRESIDENTIAL IS NOT
TO.
>> HE SHOULD HAVE WORN A MESS
TODAY.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
WEAR A MASK TO PROTECT THE
COMMUNITY.
MAYBE MIKE PENCE WANTS TO CATCH
IT ALREADY AND BE PUT OUT OF HIS
MISERY.
>> THAT WAS NICE PEOPLE.
WAS ANDREW CUOMO WEARING A MASK
IN THE HAMPTONS THE OTHER DAY?
MAYBE.
THIS WHOLE MASK THING IS SETTLED
SCIENCE JUST LIKE CLIMATE
CHANGE, COURSE, IT IS NOT AND
THEY KNOW IT.
OUR OWN EXPERTS HAVE GONE FROM
PASTS AREN’T NECESSARY TO MASKS
ARE ESSENTIAL AND WE HAVE TO
WEAR THEM WHEN YOU GO JOGGING IN
JUST A FEW WEEKS’ TIME.
NOW RUSH LIMBAUGH MADE A GREAT
POINT AS HE ALWAYS DOES ON THE
RADIO THE OTHER DAY AND HE SAID
THE VIRUS ITSELF AS IT WEAKENS
AND STATES START REOPENING, THE
MEDIA COULD HAVE BEEN SELLING
PANIC, PEANUT, PANIC FOR WEEKS
AND WEEKS AND WEEKS BUT THEY
HAVE FEWER IMAGES TO SELL
HYSTERIA TO JUSTIFY
CONTINUED LOCKDOWN.
BUT THE MASK WELL, THEY ARE A
CONSTANT REMINDER.
YOU SEE THEM ASK AND YOU THINK,
YOU ARE NOT SAFE.
YOU ARE NOT BACK TO NORMAL.
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
WELL ENTER DR. FAUCI.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO DISAPPEAR
FROM THE PLANET, WHICH MEANS AS
WE GET INTO NEXT SEASON, IN MY
MIND, IT IS INEVITABLE THAT WE
WILL HAVE A RETURN OF THE VIRUS
OR MAY BE EVEN WENT AWAY.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND.
AND WHAT SCIENTIFIC BASIS IS HE
SAYING THIS?
IS IT SUBTLE SCIENCE THAT THIS
CORONAVIRUS WILL COME BACK FOR
SURE IN THE FALL?
NO, IT IS NOT SUBTLE SCIENCE.
HERE IS A TOTALLY DIFFERENT VIEW
FROM FRANCE’S PREEMINENT
INFECTIOUS DISEASE EXPERT.
>> THIS CURVE IS CALLED A
BELL CURVE.
THIS IS THE TYPICAL CURVE FOR
EPIDEMICS MOST OF THE TIME.
IT GOES LIKE THIS SO THE REBOUND
STORY IS A FANTASY INVENTED
BASED ON THE SPANISH FLU WHICH
STARTED IN THE SUMMER AND
THEREFORE HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THIS.
EPIDEMICS BEGAN.
THEY ACCELERATE.
PEER THEY
CULMINATE.
THIS IS MAXIMUM TRANCE ABILITY
AND THEY DECREASE AND SIMPLY
DISAPPEAR, AND WE DON’T KNOW WHY
WHY.
>> REMEMBER THE LAST CORONAVIRUS
WE DEALT WITH WAS SARS.
IT STARTED IN NOVEMBER, AND IT
ENDED IN JULY.
NOW WHY AREN’T MEDIA TYPES
QUESTIONING DR. FAUCI’S
ASSERTIONS?
HE HAS AMAZING EXPERIENCE AND
ALL THE WORK HE’S DONE, BUT
THAT’S QUITE AN ASSERTION AND IT
SPREADS FEAR AND PANIC.
AND WHY ISN’T ANY GOOD NEWS IN
THIS FIGHT AGAINST THE
CORONAVIRUS EVER TAKEN TO HEART?
IT IS USUALLY DISMISSED, USUALLY
BY A LOT OF THE EXPERTS AND MOST
OF THE BLUE STATE GOVERNORS.
WELL THE ANSWER IS BASED IN
SCIENCE OR GOOD JOURNALISM
PERHAPS.
SO THE ONLY ANSWER IS THAT
ELECTION-YEAR POLITICS IS
TRUMPING PRACTICAL THINKING AND
PERHAPS EVEN TRUMPING REAL
SCIENCE.
NOW, THAT IS A NATIONAL TRAGEDY
IF THAT IS THE CASE.